all
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the press
conference following the European
Council Summit we will start with the
statement of the president of the
European Council Char
[Music]
Michelle
for
inter
[Music]
El
condition
Sol
comp
de
on this topic uh the mff review we had a
very good exchange of views and it was
needed we know that there are different
opinions around the table when we
address the questions related to the
financing and to the solidarity we have
um difficult debate this is not new but
this debate was a very good occasion to
to clarify to improve the mutual
understanding among the the leaders and
I would say there are two important
elements that we have discussed today
and that will help us in the weeks uh to
come to clarify and I hope to make some
fundamental decision the first question
is what are our common priorities for
this mff review uh we have observed that
many uh leaders are extremely clear
about the importance to support Ukraine
but we have also discussed other
priorities that maybe will be taken into
account based on the decision that we
will make competitiveness uh Sol it
notably in case of natural disasters
defense these are examples this is not
exhaustive but examples of possible
priorities that we should address in
this debate on the mff review there were
also some conversations about the
interest weights and the importance to
guarantee the transparency with regard
with this part of the political
discussion and the second point is
financing how do we pay how do we finds
for our common priorities and this a
traditional debate uh what is the
ambition in terms of what we call Fresh
money question number one and what's the
ambition in terms of redeployment uh in
order to make sure that we can adapt uh
the initial budget with the the needs
and with the priorities for the the
years to come and uh the question of the
own resources uh was also mentioned by
various leaders next next steps uh the
uh presidency of the council uh Pedro
Sanchez and his team together with the
Ambassador cor the cor they will work
further with the support of the
commission uh to prepare uh the decision
that we need to make and when we will
see and feel that this is appropriate
the European Council will have the
responsibility uh to uh uh to um uh
discuss uh the topic and to finalize uh
the decision making process we have a
common goal a common ambition this is to
make an agreement by the end of the year
this is ambitious because we do not
underestimate the level of difficulties
this is a difficult debate a difficult
discussion but there is a common common
will a common political goal to do
everything for making possible this
agreement by the end of the year I thank
you thank you very much president of the
European commission Ura vand you have
the floor thank you very much uh good
evening or better good morning um indeed
we had a long and good and intense
discussion about the situation in the
Middle East the overall position was
very clear Israel is a democracy
attacked by Hamas a terrorist
organization Israel has the right of
self-defense in line with international
law and International humanitarian law
there was a strong call from the leaders
that Hamas must immediately release all
hostages without any
preconditions and it was clear that
through its terrorist activities Hamas
is also bringing harm to the Palestinian
people Hamas has provoked a humanitarian
crisis in Gaza for the commission is
very important that we continue to
intensify our our efforts to deal with
the humanitarian crisis in
Gaza the aid needs to reach Gaza
unhindered and
quickly the 56 tons of Aid that our two
first humanitarian flights brought to
Egypt have now been delivered to Gaza
this is important but of course more is
needed we will have our next two flights
they are scheduled for today Friday and
more are planed planned over the
following days furthermore we are
progressing fast on the implementation
of the additional 50 million EUR of
extra humanitarian aid for Gaza you
might recall uh the humanitarian aid for
Gaza was planned 25 million and a week
ago approximately we tripled it to 75
million e now um these additional 50
million have to be implemented tomorrow
we will sign contract worth 40 million
with un agencies and the other 10
million will be used for the airbridge
flight that I just
mentioned we also discussed with leaders
the real risk of regionalization of the
conflict we need to continue working
intensively with Partners it was good to
hear the intense Outreach all the
leaders describ with different partners
in the region most importantly with
Egypt the current situation reinforces
our determination to work on a
comprehensive and mutual benefici
beneficial partnership with Egypt we are
in the course of developing the
different elements of this partnership
it is important for us to have Egypt as
a beacon of stability in that
region we also discussed the fact that
the crisis has implications on the eu's
internal
security uh um leaders describe the
rapid spread of online hate speech and
terrorist propaganda with the risk that
this translates into violence and
terrorists
acts with the terrorist content online
regulation and with the DSA we have
tools we have tools that we can use to
ask the platforms to take for example
terrorist content off the platform our
experience with europol is that there is
an immediate response when flagged
terrorist on online content so in less
than an hour most of the in most of the
cases the platforms are taking down this
content this is good but it requires
intensive work um online to discover the
difficult content and of course to flag
it to the platform
members we also had a discussion um that
included the fact that a very
significant increase in anti-Semitic
acts is
observed we must continue to be very
Vigilant on all other hate crimes and
therefore I took the opportunity again
to urge leaders that we can now agree on
the commission's proposal to add hate
speech and hate crime to the list of EU
crimes now indeed the second topic we
discussed was um the mff revision
proposal we should keep in mind that
when the mff was designed and decided it
was in approved in
2020 you all know since then the crisis
we have lived through the
pandemic a major economic crisis has
barely been uh prevented avoided we have
a major land war in Europe we went
through a massive energy crisis we had
the highest influx of migrants since the
migration crisis 20 2015 and now the
crisis in Middle East in other words the
world is a completely different place
compared to
2020 um we are fully aware that these
crisis do not only affect uh the limits
of the budget of the European Union but
also the member states have a lot of
constraints what that is concerned we
discussed the priorities what are the
priorities let me recall uh the most
important one of course it is the 15 50
billion Euro um support for Ukraine for
the next four years second migration is
a
priority um migration needs a European
response and this needs funding we have
several times acknowledged the need for
a comprehensive partnership with
countries of origin or Transit and this
needs funding too but we also need need
additional financing for our growth plan
for example in the western Balkans and
of course for the Border management uh
for member states facing migratory
pressures and finally last but not least
also for The Pact the moment it is um
agreed the third priority concerns
natural disasters and humanitarian
crisis the floods the droughts the
earthquakes um the wildfires you all
were witnessing this this led to the
fact that now we are already using funds
of
2024 to um give relieve uh to member
states with these um experiences of
either natural disasters or humanitarian
crisis so we need here an uh increase of
the funding too and the fourth topic is
competitiveness here is important to be
very Vigilant that we keep the clean
tech industry in Europe um you know the
pressure me that are on the clean tech
industry and the effects of the
inflation reduction act the inflation
reduction Act is relatively fast and
predial because it's um tax breaks um we
have therefore uh two elements that we
can use on the European level not having
taxes on the European level the one is
state aid and the other one is our
proposal of Step a
fund that needs an initial funding to be
then leveraged and gives then the access
to different European funds for
companies that need an answer or an
alternative for the inflation reduction
act so these were very different topics
that we discussed uh intensively today
and thank you for the moment thank you
president we'll start with questions
from the room
Austine yes uh thank you um I'm Austin
palok from you releas from Croatia you
didn't mention kosova Serbia did you
discuss it today or not and since you
were in the meeting with the two leaders
uh what's your reading uh about the
failure of them to agree prime minister
of Koso said that Serbia refused to sign
he was ready to accept and sign uh
president of Serbia vui said that uh he
was he doesn't want to sign and he
mentions some of the elements of the
agreement that he doesn't want even to
implement those who are related to the
territorial Integrity of kosov and so on
and the question for president of the
commission commission still keeps
measures against Kosovo for almost 5
months there are no measures against
Serbia some even some leaders of member
states are questioning the role of the
commission uh saying that is this uh uh
uh biased or it's enough balanced
towards both sides so is commission
considering to withdraw the measures of
Co against Kosovo to put measures
against Serbia or anything about that
thank
you thank you we had indeed um today two
meetings one with um prime minister Cy
and another one with president vuich and
then we had the European council meeting
but today we didn't address in the
European council meeting the situation
in Kosovo and and Serbia you know that
we support the normalization we support
the deescalation and tomorrow we have
the occasion in the European Council to
address this question yes I can be brief
there is an investigation ongoing and we
have said several times that when the
investigation is concluded then we will
decide on taking measures and what kind
of measures
David thank you David K radi radical
Italian radio um first of all a question
on on Gaza and humanitarian
situation um the president of the
commission said clearly that amas is
responsible for the humanitarian crisis
last week we heard the president of the
council saying that the siege of of Gaza
is against International humanitarian
law so I would ask you to clarify
according to you who is responsible for
this humanitarian
crisis um and the question on mff if um
if I may in case of
redeployment what should be cut Erasmus
Horizon uh cision because at the end of
the day if there is
redeployment there will be less money
for the actual program thank
you just a quick answer to the first uh
question uh you absolutely right that uh
few days ago one week ago I made the
point that a total Siege is not in line
with the international law and I confirm
this a principle of international law a
total Siege is not in line with the
international law many leaders address
this topic of of The Siege but there is
one one thing very clear uh there is a
serious deterioration of the
humanitarian situation in Gaza and
that's why we think that the EU should
do everything which is possible in order
to to help resolve this question of the
humanitarian access and uh the
conclusions that you have agreed uh
today are very explicit on the fact that
we want to be uh very uh determined to
try to have a positive influence on that
question point one and point two uh we
also think that the PO process is
extremely important that's why I would
like to highlight again the fact that we
took time to discuss the two- State
solution and to discuss the need for all
the partners but also for the EU uh to
try to play a strong role a positive
role and it's why we express the idea
that uh we support the principle of
holding in the EU or somewhere else and
with other parts but on holding very
soon a peace conference which is in our
opinion a good way uh to guarantee in
the future and in the long term a
sustainable peace and sustainable
stability in this
region it is important that we always
keep in mind that on the 7th of October
it all started with a horrible attack by
Hamas terrorists um on the people of
Israel and I think it is important that
we
acknowledge the pain and the suffering
of um the Israeli
people and the families that lost
relatives or where relatives are
hostages if if we want to speak to
Israel and influence
Israel um and therefore it is so
important that you first listen if you
want to be listened to um it was
important and very good that so many
leaders traveled to Israel to listen to
Israel but also to speak very clearly on
the need to um exerting the uh right of
self-defense to do this in line with
international law and of course um
leaders emphasized that The Siege must
stop and um that it is of utmost
importance that the Palestinian people
and the hostages and all those who are
in Gaza have access to humanitarian
Aid thank you there is no contradiction
between showing solidarity to Israel and
of course acting on the need of
humanitarian Aid for the people of
Gaza thank you
batri oh yeah thank you forgot you're
right um so we discussed what we
discussed today are what are the
possibilities either you have National
contributions or uh you can redeploy or
we have new own resources there is the
proposal for new own resources on the
table but this will take take a certain
time we have some new own resources for
example seum but this will only um
deliver as of
2028 um therefore today I described to
leaders what the uh trade-offs are and
indeed um if we look at the trade-offs
um if you do not use National
contribution you have to look at the
budget the budget consists of 23 of uh C
or 2third of the budget is cohesion and
agricultural funds onethird are the
other programs like Erasmus like Horizon
so there was as you can imagine an
intensive discussion about uh how to
finance the request for the revision no
decision has been taken so we will see
the effect uh the the the result uh at
the end of the
negotiations hi OS for the Washington
Post um on the statement you talk about
humanitarian corridors and poses um and
I was wondering what is the next step
are you going to reach out to Partners
in the International Community but also
to Israel and through mediation to Hamas
to make sure that those passes actually
take place and that it can reach Gaza
thank
you since day one we are extremely
active at the Diplomatic level on the EU
side but also together with with our
member states and many leaders are in
close contact with the countries in the
region with the leaders of the countries
in the region with Israel of course and
we do not give up we think this
extremely important and Urgent to make
possible the delivery of humanitarian
Aid is one first element and my second
point is related to the political
process again I would like to repeat
that there was a very uh very large
consensus among the the member states
and the leaders uh to work actively to
make possible such an International
Peace conference and you know that a few
days ago I was together with some other
European leaders and and Arab leaders in
a meeting in Egypt you know that in this
meeting President CC with the support of
many leaders of theion proposed to hold
a conference within six months it was a
proposal put on the table by presid CC
and it means that we we want to engage
with all the partners in the region but
not only in the region to coordinate our
efforts on both sides humanitarian
humanitarian support Human Assistance is
extremely urgent I repeat again but at
the same time in paral we think is very
important to relaunch a serious
political uh process based on the
two-state
solution indeed um it is of utmost
importance to speak with all the actors
in the region and I mentioned uh before
the manifold visits of leaders uh to
Israel but also to other countries like
Jordan or Egypt for example and it is
very good that this Outreach takes place
because we have to do everything
possible to prevent a spill over in The
Wider region um and there Europe has a
role to play and therefore I very much
welcome the result of the discussions
tonight reflected in uh the
conclusions thank you
Christian
for
[Music]
Le
for
terorist Hamas is a terrorist
organization without any question and um
we have to fight Hamas um like any
terrorist organization Hamas in its
militant um behavior and terroristic as
a terroristic organization has to be
destroyed but other countries have a lot
of influence in the region and this is
visible by the release of hostages and
this is very good and we are very
grateful for uh those countries taken
the initiative and using their influence
to
deescalate and uh to find uh a solution
for the hostages and to find
possibilities to have the release of
hostages thank you very much
J the
mff I keep forgetting that
part I like it but we had the
discussions yeah and it it was I mean I
think this is the the very end the
secret of negotiations at the end you
have a mixture of
everything so uh so we we we H this was
the excessive
deficit yes I just had forgotten the in
content of it's too late I'm too
tired two questions in one are too
difficult for me at this stage um so uh
we we have rules and we have to look
into these rules um you know it's very
hard to say what kind of um uh what kind
of requirements uh the the member states
are faced as long as you have not
finished um the discussion but um we're
going back to the regular mechanism next
year after having the Escape Clause the
Escape Clause will end and uh there will
be a transition into the
regular um uh the regular handling of
the questions of for example excessive
deficit
procedure president you want to
okay um Valero with Bloomberg uh
question on the peace conference um the
conclusion said that uh leaders supports
the the conference but does that mean
that the EU is willing to to lead the
effort in organizing this this
conference what what it means very soon
as you said now president Michelle uh do
you think that uh Hamas has to be
represented in any way in this
conference and also um our understanding
was that this proposal came from
president Sanchez but you just said now
that actually the idea was discussed in
El kaido and he was put on the table by
President L CI so it will be be good if
you could clarify I mean where the idea
came from and also I mean to know
whether Arab countries is already are
already supporting this idea thank
you two or three two or three um
elements and and indeed this this idea
was already on the table during this
meeting in Egypt uh and president
Sanchez today insisted on the importance
to take it into account and also to
support such a possible initiative we we
don't want at this stage to be too too
precise to conrete because we want to
engage with our partners and to and to
make it happen and soon means soon it
means that we hope that in the weeks and
months to come we can make progress and
for that we need to engage and to
discuss the modalities not through the
Press but to discuss the modalities with
all the possible uh Partners to make
such a conference happen and also to try
to to make it a success if this is
possible to launch a peace process and
to use such a confence then we want we
want to work to make a success with all
our partners without preempting all the
the modalities and to be to be clear
Hamas is a terrorist organization and we
want to engage with the leaders and the
JS in the countries Hamas is the
organization that's why I don't see any
role for Hamas in such an International
Conference in which the EU would
participate we go but take two more
questions and we wrap it up I think it's
late for everyone so step Mark and then
we go in the
middle
even a mic uh question for the
commission president I promise only one
topic uh it's the mff um when you
presented the review in June he actually
presented it as a minimum
package it was the absolute minimum what
what what was needed and now today you
heard actually several heads of state
saying but we have also some other
priorities so these two things combined
and the unwillingness to come up with
with redeployment or extra money
how do likely do you think there will be
an agreement in December and two could
you live if the Ida to split the review
so only agree in December about the
Ukraine facility and and decide about
the other topics uh in 24 25 thanks I do
not see that the um revision will be
split because there was a very clear
positioning of um many leaders that uh
this is not in their interest and that
they would not tolerate a splitting
um so overall there was a lot of support
for the priorities um because indeed um
typically when you design a overall B
budget you have some buffers in it we
have not done this this time if you look
at the figures and if you look at the
topics it's the bare minimum and that is
necessary I mean Ukraine is
self-explanatory uh migration everybody
knows um that for the for example
external action we are doing with
partner countries we need more funding
the natural disasters and humanitarian
Aid I do not have to explain how
difficult the situation is and we should
not forget we planned uh the budget in
2020 so you have all the slices every
year for seven years fixed there's not a
lot of uh flexibility in and the
important topic of uh competitiveness
which is Step there was a broad I would
not say 100% but a broad support more or
less for these priorities yes you are
right if I recall it correct um mostly
the topic of defense or military
Mobility was also um uh brought forward
but uh certainly not by a vast
majority um so I think it's taking shape
what we're looking at now the question
is um of course there will be a mixture
in the very end of um possible
redeployment and natural
contributions uh you have the options uh
to reduce um the proposals or you have
the option to take one part of The
Proposal out uh explicitly not a split
but we have five different elements in
it so if we look at for example uh that
one part uh as one element would be
taken out these are the options that are
on the table and um the Spanish
presidency has done an intensive work by
presenting by now three nego boxes so so
um and this work will now go on it was
very important to hear the leaders and
to get an idea where the majorities
might be and what um the views on the
overall the political view this is not a
detailed figure view we were not
discussing figures for example but the
political view on uh the mff revision
what it looks
like maybe a few points on the on the
mff because it's very important to have
a clear view on the on the process uh
and we remember that four years ago when
we had an agreement on the initial
budget uh it was a very difficult debate
and a very difficult political decision
and it will be again a very difficult
political decision in the weeks in the
weeks to come even if all of us we are
aware that there's a certain sense of
urgency and it would be great if we are
able to make an agreement uh by the end
of the year which is I repeat our common
goal in terms of priorities I can share
with you that many leaders indeed
support the idea that Ukraine should be
one priority and then there were various
opinions among the leaders about the
other topics and indeed competitiveness
uh defense uh solidarity fund and the
natural disasters these were examples
mentioned by various leaders where we
should make sure that the EU will have
the tools and the means to act and to
react in case of need this my my first
point it means that there are debates
and there and there is further work that
will be needed on this of the priorities
point one and point to the financing and
here we didn't discuss today the numbers
and it will be the next step the space
presidency we have the responsibility to
put Nega on the table with numbers which
will make more concrete and more
operational the political debate we will
have on this question but there's a an
important political question that you
need to resolve this is which part of
the review uh will be financed through
fresh money and which part would be
finan to redeployments in the initial
budget I don't want to preempt this
discussion but today for the first time
at the level of the leaders we had the
occasion to listen to each other to
understand uh what are the very uh the
very important key priorities for all
the leaders what are the very difficult
points in the concession that will be
difficult for the for the leaders it
means that this debate was extremely
useful to make uh the next step and the
spainish presidency will put on the
table a Neo box with numbers that time
and then we'll assess when it will be
possible for the European Council to be
ceased of this matter and to try to make
the final decisions on this question
thank you very much we'll wrap up here
it's already very late so thank you very
much president we'll see you tomorrow
thank
you
an phob was toally part of the political
discussion and the second point is
financing how do we pay how do we
Finance for our common priorities and
this a traditional debate uh what rep
the cair they will work further with the
support of the commission this is
ambitious because we do not
underestimate the level of difficulties
this is a difficult debate difficult
conditions and it was clear that through
its terrorist activ ities are
progressing fast on the implementation
of the additional 50 million EUR of
extra humanitarian aid for Gaza
additional financing for our growth plan
for example in the western Balkans and
of course for the Border management for
total seege is not in line with the
international law many leaders address
this topic um you know the pressures
that are on the clean tech industry and
the effect and thank you for the moment
thank you president we'll start with
questions from the
about the failure of them to agree prime
minister of kosa said that Serbia
refused to sign Siege of of Gaza is
against International humanitarian law
so of October it all started with a
horrible attack by Hamas terrorists uh